what's up guys I'm super excited
Vin Diesel the rock and that blonde guy
are back in Fast six and it has inspired
me I want to see if I have what it takes
to do a little street racing I'm going
to take my ride into some actual
real-life auto mechanics and see what it
takes to get fast
[Music]
great Thom here with mark of VIP
automotive so if I wanted to street race
this Scion what would I want to do to it
now you can put a supercharger on it
they'll be intimidating
what's a supercharger it's a unit that
goes on the intake manifold that
provides up what's the intake manifold
it's part of the engine system what's an
engine system how capable is this rig of
launching itself off a dock at a high
speed and flying like a hundred yards
and landing perfectly on a boat never
happened what all right what can you do
to make this happen
put some wings on it so I'm here with
Jeff from euro-spec automotive I'm
interested in maybe doing some street
racing if I wanted to roll up on the
secret street race location intimidate
what could I do to this car to make it
BAM I could never be intimidated by a
Scion all right so I'm here with Kenny
from N&W Independent German auto repair
you ever driven an illegal car race yes
are you a better driver than Dominic
Toretto it's only one way to find out
bring on the challenge
you hear that Vin Diesel he's calling
you out in Fast Five they pull a ten-ton
safe through the streets of Brazil could
this car manage that absolutely no yeah
you could probably toast something ten
tons and you would move all of ginger
four or five miles an hour why you did
it with the engine fully max market VIP
automotive said I could not pull ten
tons is this car suitable for drifting
yeah you can probably make it a drift
car yes is it advisable for me to pick
up a drifter a drift or not and one of
the fast movies uh they've flames coming
out of the exhaust how does that work
well it's pretty simple thing actually
you have to install a spark plug into
the exhaust or some source of ignition
best of Raleigh just inject propane or
even pure gasoline into the exhaust
stream fire the spark plugs rev the
engine you're gonna shoot flames about
20 feet out the back Jeff you are like a
greasy mr. wizard
how fast do the cops go they could
probably do about 140 miles an hour how
much would it cost in modifications to
get this thing up to 190 miles an hour
I think the fastest way to do that would
be to drop it out of a plane
is this car suitable for smuggling drugs
from the Mexican border yes okay will
you help me put like a little
compartment in there where I could keep
my gat oh hell yeah yes absolutely six
hundred cash no receipt let's say the
Scion gets blown off the track and I
need to upgrade and I find a car but I
don't get it in the most honest way you
do something about those VIN numbers
yeah you can chop those grind nose right
off you help me lose those VIN numbers
no how much would serious modifications
cost me I would say probably right
around about $4,000
a good ten grand you'd be looking
probably ten to twenty thousand dollars
what I really think if you want this
thing to get nice you should just invest
in running drugs in fact if you need a
front or a middleman we could talk I
mean this could be the beginning of a
business opportunity got some hookups
like I said I know a couple people here
and there what if I wanted to watch you
or one of your mechanics make love to my
wife that's up to you no problem turns
out I can't afford to be fast and that
makes me furious so that episode got me
thinking who's better Vin Diesel or the
rock the rock or Vin Diesel who do you
like better leave us an answer in the
comment section below
best answer get the screen junkies
t-shirt help us settle the greatest
debate of our time hey do you love
t-shirts but hate commenting on videos
now you're in luck click on the link in
the description below and you can buy
one of these screen junkies t-shirts
like the one I wore in the video or this
honest trailer shirt pretty sweet or
wait for it ding this screen junkies
hooded sweatshirt with the phrase we
like to watch we personally like to
watch movies and stuff what do you like
to watch your neighbors stepping out of
the shower hey just don't get caught
okay so anyway they're there if you want
them thanks for watching
I'm how Rudnik by bike
[Music]